once a busy navigation channel for light
fishing vessels
this portion of the lake chart is now a
crossing point for cattle
decades of poor water usage
celts
droughts and the impact of climate
change
continue to alter the face of the lake
and with it the lives of millions who
depend on it
this family
is forced to migrate because of drought
not far from here we met a fisherman
pulling in his catch of the day
he says it's the most he got in a week
a few macros not enough to feed his
family
we used to catch a lot of fish in past
years with little effort but it's so
much more difficult now i'm lucky to
have even caught this much
he says fishermen like him must learn
other skills to survive the hard times
the leg chart is shared by cameroon chad
niger and nigeria countries dealing with
a 12 year old boko haram insurgency that
has killed thousands and displaced
millions
experts say the conflict is fueled in
part by the effects of climate change
lake chad's one of the world's biggest
lakes but over 50 years it's changed
dramatically what was once a 25 000
kilometer body of water is now estimated
at scattered islands like this and pools
just containing 1 000 square kilometers
and that has left 25 million people
short of food and jobs and exposed to
conflicts
30 kilometers away from what is now the
new shores of the lake as this hasn't
have a sogum after five months of labor
and a four thousand dollar investment
different quality is not good quality
now the quality it's not good quality
about 40 hectares that's the only thing
we got this year for 40 hectares not
enough because we've got problems with
the rain
he says he will be lucky to get four
bikes this year which amounts to a 3 800
loss on his investment
a few decades ago what he now calls a
farm was deep inside the lake chart
for generations this sahelian oasis has
supported millions of families
livestock and profitable trade among
nations
governments in the region are struggling
to address the fears and concerns of
millions who now watch helplessly as
their means of livelihoods dry up
just as industrialized countries agreed
to support developing countries chad
through its public treasury will also
fund projects to mitigate the impact of
climate change on its people
little comfort to those who lost so much
back at aziz hassan's farm his workers
continue to process this year's harvest
but at the back of their minds they are
conscious of the reality that they like
millions in the region may not get to
keep their jobs next year
ahmed idris al-jazeera on the shores of
the lake chant